the movie begins in a prison cell where
Khloe SAA a mentally ill criminal is
having a counseling session with
psychiatrist Dr Miranda gray Chloe
insists the devil Revisited her last
night and physically assaulted her
however Dr Gray doubts her story
suggesting it might be her stepfather
instead Khloe denies it explaining that
she had killed him with her own hands as
Dr Gray notes down her words Khloe's
frustration boils over she is enraged
that everyone dismisses her truth
labeling her as insane Miranda has heard
enough and abruptly ends the session in
response Khloe lashes out and is
escorted back to her cell Dr Miranda
gray is a psychiatrist at Woodward
penitentiary in rural Connecticut she
regularly counsels Khloe to see if her
mental health is improving however she
believes Khloe is making up satanic
stories to cope with the guilt of
killing her stepfather after her recent
session she expresses her frustration to
Dr Douglas gray senior psychiatrist and
her husband in response Dr Douglas or
Doug reassures her that she will find a
way to help Khloe in due time exhaust it
after a long day the couple share a kiss
before being interrupted by their
colleague Dr Pete Graham after a brief
conversation Doug informs his wife that
he will visit his Cottage in Willow
Creek on the way home seizing the
opportunity Pete flirts with Miranda and
suggests they go for coffee however
Miranda spends the rest of the evening
working on Khloe's file to unwind at the
end of the day she decides to go for a
swim later that night it is raining
heavily as Miranda prepares to leave for
home Pete walks her to her car with an
umbrella he is clear L into Miranda and
follows her car downhill from where they
go their separate ways a little further
down the road Miranda's car is stopped
by a police patrol sheriff Bob Ryan a
close friend of Doug tells her the road
is closed due to a sinkhole He suggests
she take a Deeter down the road and
threw a little white wooden bridge to
reach her home on her way Miranda calls
Doug to let him know she will be there
in a few minutes as she struggles to get
her message across due to poor Network
reception she suddenly spots a girl
standing in the middle of the road
Miranda swerves her car to avoid hitting
the girl and ends up crashing by the
roadside shaken but determined Miranda
gingerly approaches the girl the girl
stands Motionless in the pouring rain
her white night gown completely soaked
as Miranda comes face to face with the
girl she notices a deep gash on her
chest concerned Miranda reassures the
crying girl that she is a doctor and
will help her abruptly the girl begins
to shake violently and bursts into
flames Miranda lets out a loud scream as
the girl grabs her face with her flaming
hand next thing we know Miranda wakes up
with a gasp and horrifyingly finds
herself in an observation cell of
Woodward Penitentiary she lashes out
demanding an explanation which prompts
the staff to restrain her her anger
subsides slightly when Dr Pete Graham
enters for a one-on-one conversation
Pete explains that he has secured a
court waiver to treat her until her
transfer to prison he reveals that she
has been there for 3 days due to severe
brain damage that triggered multiple
seizures Pete then asks if she recalls
anything from that night Miranda pieces
together fragments of her memory and
tries to tell him about the girl she
encountered at the bridge however Pete
dismisses any talk about the girl and
instructs her to focus on the last thing
she remembers about Doug he then
delivers the shocking news that Doug is
dead and she is the prime suspect in his
murder Miranda's emotions spiral out of
control forcing the staff to sedate her
as the sedative takes effect she
experiences flashbacks of a bloody scene
the next day Miranda joins the other
inmates in the penitentiary's
recreational area she tries to separate
herself from her former patients by
sitting alone on a bench but Khloe joins
her Chloe mocks Miranda remarking that
she now understands how it feels to be
misunderstood because people think she
is crazy as Khloe leaves she tosses a
piece of paper at Miranda it is a
newspaper clipping detailing the brutal
murder of Dr Douglas gray by his wife Dr
Miranda gray that night in her cell the
lights begin to flicker erratically
Miranda hears heavy breathing outside
her cell but sees no one suddenly fog
envelopes the glass wall followed by a
chilling message not alone Miranda tries
to rationalize her experience convincing
herself it was just a dream she curls up
in the corner with her head buried in
her hands to her surprise she is jolted
up by a nurse with medication almost
immediately reluctantly Miranda takes
the medicine and joins the other inmates
for her first communal shower while
taking a shower she is startled by the
sight of the girl she had encountered at
the bridge panic-stricken Miranda runs
around scaring and irritating other
inmates the girl follows Miranda around
the shower and slashes her arm leaving
her bleeding on the floor the doctors
swiftly bandaged Miranda's arm and
conclude that she slashed herself 35
times using a stolen scalpel the nurse
discloses that Khloe has been placed in
solitary confinement as she was seen
threatening Miranda earlier meanwhile
Pete arrives for a routine checkup and
Miranda vehemently denies cutting
herself in response Pete suggests
increasing her medication dosage to stop
her hallucinations and urges her to
trust him Miranda repeats Khloe's words
from their earlier encounter you can't
trust somebody when they think you are
crazy following the checkup Miranda and
the other patients are escorted to the
prison yard here she requests Dr Phil to
assign her a new doctor instead of Pete
however Dr Phil declines firmly stating
that Pete is one of his finest
Physicians Miranda then notices Pete
observing her through a small window in
the next scene Miranda meets her lawyer
Teddy declares her innocence in Doug's
murder and laments everyone treating her
like a crazy person however Teddy
presents overwhelming evidence against
her including fingerprints on the murder
weapon and at the crime scene he advises
her to plead Insanity to delay the
hearing scheduled for the following week
increasingly alienated Miranda realizes
that even Teddy doesn't believe her
meanwhile Sheriff Bob Ryan summons
Miranda for questioning despite Teddy's
reluctance Miranda agrees to meet Bob
convinced of her innocence however the
meeting quickly escalates into a heated
confrontation as an emotionally
distraught Bob accuses her of murdering
his best friend he presents gruesome
photographs of the crime scene depicting
dismembered body parts and the Blood
Stained message not alone on the door
suddenly Teddy notices something strange
with Miranda's bandaged arm to
everyone's shock the words not alone are
etched into her arm in the aftermath of
the incident Miranda is sedated once
again triggering flashbacks of the
fateful day she envisions herself
unlocking her house clutching the axe
and standing in front of a horrified
Doug the girl from the bridge reappears
and she also sees herself engulfed in
flames after the girl grabbed her face
the following morning she visits Phil in
her office under the watchful eye of
Pete she admits that she was there in
her home at the time of the murder
however she adds she was not alone which
is what the Not Alone written on the
wall means but before they can move
forward with the conversation her eyes
fall on the photo of a young girl kept
behind Dr Phil she quickly grabs the
photo and reveals this is the girl that
she saw on the bridge that she has been
seeing everywhere Dr Phil says that it
is her daughter Rachel Parson in the
photo but she died 4 years ago that
night alone in herself cell Miranda
attempts to communicate with Rachel
parsons's ghost asking for her release
from the cell the door miraculously
unlocks and Miranda rushes towards her
office only to find it locked she then
heads to Pete's office where she
discovers a newspaper article detailing
Rachel parsons's suicide on the computer
screen a window on the computer flickers
open revealing Rachel's ghost standing
outside solitary confinement Miranda
realizes Khloe is there and rushes to
her rescue however before she can open
the door she Witnesses Khloe being
violently assaulted by a man with a
tattoo depicting a woman engulfed in
flames on his chest terrified Miranda
fleas the scene only to be apprehended
by guards the following day Miranda is
taken to Pete's for further consultation
she recounts her encounter with the
tattooed man Pete identifies the tattoo
as animus Sola a Biblical depiction of a
woman enduring temporary suffering while
awaiting her fate which he believes
mirrors Miranda's mental turmoil
dismissive of his interpretation Miranda
insists that Rachel parsons's death was
not a suicide EX desperated Pete labels
her delusional and leaves the room that
afternoon Chloe is finally released from
solitary confinement Miranda approaches
her and apologizes for doubting her
story to her surprise Khloe Embraces her
and delivers a chilling message the
devil says you are next following her
escape attempt Miranda was sent to
solitary confinement for the night
however she is attacked by Rachel
parsons's ghost who tosses her around
the cell the guards monitoring the
security cameras witnessed this as
Miranda's apparent self harm attempt and
rushed to her Aid as a guard enters her
cell Miranda knocks him over snatches
the keys and Sprints towards the exit
she navigates the passageways and
staircases eventually reaching the pool
she frequented for swimming she
submerges herself deep within the pool
evading the two guards searching for her
as they turn to leave she spots Rachel
parsons's ghost approaching her
fortunately the water muffles her scream
preventing her from being detected with
the assistance of Joe the friendly
security guard Miranda successfully
evades the guards moreover Joe even
provides her with the keys to his car
enabling Miranda to escape the prison as
she speeds away she notices the ghost in
the back seat and tries to stop the
vehicle however the brakes fail and she
narrowly avoids a collision with an
oncoming truck before she can regain her
composure she crashes the car just
before the massive sinkhole that blocked
the road upon reaching her former home
Miranda is startled by the lights
automatically turning on as she enters
she is flooded with flashbacks of the
murder aame Doug drags himself through
the hallway pleading for his life
Miranda sees herself wielding the axe
delivering the final blow that ends
Doug's life the flashbacks intensify as
she enters the bedroom through the blood
splattered door in the bathroom she
Witnesses herself submerged in a bathtub
filled with blood as she Rises and
confronts her reflection in the mirror
she fights against Rachel's ghost
possessing her the flashbacks fade and
Miranda's memory is now completely
restored she sits down with a photo of
Doug and her tears streaming down her
face as she questions why she had taken
his life suddenly a drop of Blood Falls
on the photo reminding her of Doug's
frequent visits to Willow Creek the next
morning Miranda travels to Doug's small
cottage in Willow Creek as she explores
the old wooden home she stumbles upon
rails of photos scattered on the floor
upon closer inspection she discovers a
hidden hatch leading to an underground
passage underground she switches on what
appears to be studio lights and is met
with a horrifying sight a bed splattered
with drops of blood chains drugs and a
video camera curious and afraid she
plays the video camera and Witnesses a
disturbing scene dud forcing himself on
a restrained girl on the same blood
soaked bed with a chilling realization
dud turns to the camera and utters the
words it's good to be there God this
Revelation shatters Miranda's perception
of her husband exposing his dark
sadistic secret he had been kidnapping
torturing and physically assaulting
women for years all while concealing his
monstrous acts from her Miranda's train
of thought is abruptly interrupted by
footsteps from upstairs instinctively
she hides in a dark corner but her
attempt to evade capture proves feudal a
policeman Corners her and simultaneously
a pair of arms grab Miranda from behind
out of the darkness emerges from the
blooded and bruised face of the girl who
was in the video she pleads for help to
Miranda's shock the girl is revealed to
be Tracy a missing person reported a
week ago news of the horrifying
Revelation spreads like wildfire
captivating the media's attention the
reporter poses a question to sheriff Bob
Ryan inquiring whether the FBI was
taking over the investigation meanwhile
Miranda is confined to an interrogation
room where Dr Phil pays her a visit Phil
is deeply shaken by the revelation of
Doug's crimes a man he had considered a
trusted friend and colleague for years
Miranda calmly asserts that Rachel
Phil's daughter had not committed
suicide but is instead a victim of
Doug's murderous actions she firmly
believes that Rachel's ghost is
attempting to communicate with her
sending messages from Beyond the Grave
Miranda desperately seeks Pete's
assistance hoping he would help her she
explains how the man with the anima Sola
tattoo is connected to the recent
murders but Pete dismisses her
Supernatural beliefs insisting that she
abandoned her delusions realizing Pete
was unwilling to help Miranda requests
to speak with Sheriff Bob Ryan however
she is informed of his absence from the
prison and is assured that her message
will be relayed to him reluctantly Pete
delves into research about the anima
Sola tattoo meanwhile Miranda alone in
her cell receives an unexpected visit
from Sheriff Bob Ryan she pleads with
him to hear her out calmly and they
settle into a convers ation within her
cell Miranda explains that the phrase
not alone signifies the presence of two
killers one being Doug and the other the
man bearing the burning Woman tattoo on
his chest surprisingly Bob readily
accepts Miranda's claims even asking her
to create a profile of this tattooed
individual drawing upon her expertise in
Psychiatry Miranda informs him that this
man must have been Doug's Apprentice has
unresolved motherly issues derived
pleasure from harming animals during his
childhood and struggles with his sexual
identity as a man Shar sh Bob becomes
visibly uneasy prompting him to delve
deeper into questioning Miranda
throughout their conversation Miranda
gradually realizes that her profile
perfectly matched Bob's characteristics
and the only reason he sought her input
was to cover up his involvement in the
murders abruptly Sheriff Bob Ryan
Springs up attempting to sedate Miranda
however the lights mysteriously switch
off and Miranda seizes the opportunity
to stab the injection into Bob's neck
before making an escape ripping off his
shirt and revealing the anima Soul a
tattooed on his chest Bob pursues
Miranda relentlessly firing his gun
indiscriminately one of the bullets hits
a gas pipeline causing a gas leak to
develop Miranda runs to an office
upstairs and hides under a table Bob
cautiously searches the room his shotgun
poised ready to fire at the slightest
movement as he approaches the table a
shadow diverts his attention leading him
away emboldened by the temporary
distraction Bob begins to confess their
heinous crimes he reveals that he and
Doug had abducted Rachel Parsons
subjecting her to the same torment they
had inflicted upon countless local women
slowly the injection makes Bob feel
disoriented but he manages to spot a
girl standing across from him through a
window mistaking her for Miranda he
Fires at the glass shattering it to his
shock he realizes the girl is Rachel
Parsons and he impulsively shoots her
however the bullet triggers the leaked
gas causing an explosion that engulfs
Bob in Flames mirroring the burning
Woman tattoo on his chest emerging from
her hiding spot Miranda aims her gun at
Bob and fires a shot into his head an
act of Retribution for his heinous
crimes just Then Pete arrives at the
scene and apologizes to Miranda for not
believing her story the next scene takes
us ahead by a year Miranda and Khloe are
seen strolling down the street their
charges finally dropped Chloe still
struggles with vivid dreams while
Miranda claims to have suppressed those
memories for good Chloe expresses her
gratitude to Miranda before departing in
a taxi to catch her train just up ahead
a young boy stands inexplicably in the
middle of the road directly in the path
of an approaching fire truck however in
a surreal turn of events the truck
passes through the boy as if he were a
ghost the film ends as Miranda continues
her walk and the camera pans to a poster
it features the image of the same boy
who had stood in the road moments
earlier his fate shrouded in mystery